[Music]
thank you for joining us and watching as
we are discussing
pets week and we are here with christian
cassares
hi thank you so much for having me here
and now christian has been covering all
week pets week and we are going to learn
a little bit about his pets and also the
stories he's been covering take it away
all right well thank you so much so yeah
so we're celebrating
pets week here at eight news now so
every day during this week we're talking
about
different topics and as a pet lover i
mean this
is just exciting for me obviously i'm
learning a lot of things so hopefully
you will too but
two of the stories that i'm covering is
pet traveling and pet insurance
so first of all for pet traveling i
commute a lot to california because my
family is out there
so we're talking about some tips on how
to keep your pets a little bit more
comfortable because sometimes that
anxiety just goes through the roof
when you're driving when you're flying
we talked to some uh
experts at petsmart and just different
places on
things like uh supplements maybe some
like anxiety jackets that you can put on
them
and also uh if you can't take them with
you when you're traveling
sometimes you know if you're going like
over to europe or like one of those like
long flights
that can be a little bit tricky so there
are great places here in town where you
can go and drop them off they're 24
7 and you can also take advantage of the
fact that
it's overnight boarding but they also do
grooming they also do
training so i mean it's amazing i mean
they
they really you know they have a great
time when they're there
yeah yeah of course and then also my
other story which will be airing
tomorrow
uh that is about pet insurance and
that's actually something that many
people forget to think about
um we all have you know our puppies our
kittens that they're great but they like
to go and chew and
eat everything and sometimes you know
they get an upset tummy and you get
worried
that you know maybe they might have
something you know going
over there and and in in their tummy
till you go to the vet
and that bill starts going up it sounds
really really telling it sounds like you
were telling on someone for a moment are
you talking about your puppy
i have so much experience going to the
vet so i've learned over the years so
hopefully you at home will uh take some
notes and save you some money
so yeah so i have uh two dogs at home
and those two right there on your screen
that is lucy and mateo lucy
is almost a one-year-old golden doodle
she's my princess she's my sweetheart
but as you can tell that she knows no
personal boundaries uh and mateo is
almost three years old he's a king
charles cavalier
and they're both great they're they're
angels but at the same time
you know anyone who has a doodle knows
that they are just so high energy
and i mean oh my god she definitely
keeps us on our toes
those stories are gonna be closer to
eight newsnails.com thank you christian
for joining us yeah no thank you for
having me i think i need to get some
tips from you too
[Music]